Presidente Trump wants to build a wall
and he would like Mexico to pay for it
would you like to make a donation do you
have any would you like to put a love
you'd put love in there no I need cash
would you like to donate to the wall oh
and I'm gonna sweeten the deal all right
if you donate 500 pesos you get your
name on a brick in the wall leave it
yeah okay and you have to act now
because there's only gonna be 800
million of these yeah for a thousand
pesos look at this you get an I paid for
the wall model back do you want that and
throwing in look at this right here
muchas gracias yeah yes that's how he
spells I think that's he want to donate
money to build the wall that anything
you'd like to say to President Trump
we have tenemos muchas cosas de Letran
he's not if you if you speak in Spanish
Trump won't understand if you speak in
English you may not understand
[Music]
I want to hug the grandmother please go
away Trump said that you would pay Trump
he said you would pay Trump said you in
pain no you can't--no
[Applause]
you